hello there reject nation we're gonna
watch ourselves from cobra kai
three by three subscribe click that
notification bell
to get notified when our next cobra car
reaction is up
listen we can only do reaction
highlights here on youtube
fooling throughout your watch alongs
where you sync it with the timecard
are available all over our patreon page
thank you all you beautiful sons and
[ __ ] and bastards for becoming
patronized
as over there we cover so many shows
we're at the same tier
you get the option for reaction
highlights and watch alongs included for
all these shows
look at this thumbnails galore you know
why because there's so many tv shows we
cover over there
hell yeah all right
let's watch this now
yeah hit that like button if you enjoy
the reaction this is where most of us go
when we think about forgiveness true
what about forgiveness in other forms no
mercy that's what i say
forgive hard forgive fast no mercy
if god can forgive then so can you but
i'm not god
those soccer moms at the hyatt god
forgive any of us for that
oh no johnny i'm in the middle of a
sermon
so how about you take us no this guy was
a real badass back in the day
sucks you're not allowed to get laid
anymore man how many times i got to tell
you
i'm not a priest i bang so many girls
still get tang
oh god
whoa whoa wow
deacon bad ass over here
oh my god the church is going to learn
karate
it's my favorite cold open so far oh now
robbie looks a little bit more like
robbie that's our table homie
it must be deaf no he's just ignoring
you i said that's our table homie
time to become a white savior yes
get in there come on superman you okay
man
it does look fresh i would love it if
this never came back around
he makes no acquaintances in jail robbie
hi i'm so glad i got you robbie people
have a way of coming around
no one hated your cousin more than i did
and
even now i have to admit he's a
decent salesman there's a character arc
so why don't you get in that car
and fly mamacita
[Laughter]
so no more kicking the competition or
shopping prices
no no you have to focus on sales
the manufacturers won't be found what
about the bonsais
what the hell is he doing here you know
he's gonna try to buy him out you walk
in here with this guy and let him talk
to me like that huh it's just how he
talks you get used to it
[Music]
you want to buy a car damn a car no
no no i want the whole show i knew it
knew it yeah
[Music]
now that's a nurse oh yeah that's gonna
be his new loving dishes
i have a surgery on friday that's great
right surgery costs a ton and my mom's
gonna be in debt
good daniel pay for it ah
i think if anyone can beat the odds it's
you
yeah and you're not that bad
kind of makes me look tough or abused
yeah it's like the body or arm it's not
the best place
you know her mom's sick and everybody's
got a sob story even crease
yeah it doesn't give you a right to be a
bully i wanted to give you this
it's just a card you can't hurt anybody
with it
octopus interesting
surprised he showed up
i still don't understand how to get the
coffee in the cake
you can't blame yourself for what robbie
did i'm not even allowed to see him not
allowed i'm on probation for that little
incident in the uh oh
that's too bad i'm lucky i knew a priest
putting a good word with the judge thank
you
not a priest you got to remember you
don't do the right thing because it
always works out you do the right thing
because it's the right thing to do
what with no benefit i mean you got to
have that mathematical
payout otherwise what's the point how
can you monetize doing what's right
the detention center will let you in if
you're accompanied by a member of the
clergy so
oh how about we meet there tomorrow oh
very great good you're a good priest
and as for miguel in his surgery why not
ask your stepdad to help out he's still
looking uh
and astr's gonna come back we'll figure
something out
you should start your own school man a
different one one that's not cobra kai
yeah johnny doe this offer is hardly
christmas morning
it's not even a belated secretary's day
gift they prefer executive assistant
oh do they it's great no one wants to do
business with a bully
it's only been a few weeks actually this
moment reminds me of getting
crap for not including a certain moment
in our episode one reaction of this
season karate is not the problem when i
went to school here i was bullied karate
saved me [ __ ] i heard you were the
real bully
i watched that youtube video back to
episode three why don't you
try and get something
before it's worth nothing
who does business with this guy i don't
know
you still over on lancashire no i grew
up on lancashire small two bedroom over
on outpost ah
more obscure street colgate owner to
convince the manufacturers to cut ties
with larussa oh
oh oh baroosh
come on let's go oh jerk
we really got to talk but i did not
hear this i did not just hear this from
a noose right now as he left
oh there's to raising money for miguel
yeah
all the after the kids are raising money
people are coloring all the people
coloring out of band together
have a couple of white chicks to boost
up sales
our awesomeness are an expression always
keeping it modern yeah you're gonna grow
to be a little horror aren't you an
ethical [ __ ]
yeah bro that rub that [ __ ] rub that
chubby
body up there yeah yeah
yeah there you go yeah
damn it my car is gonna be clean
oh no
they think they can get away with
altruism
i know that building well i've done some
maintenance work so i know how it goes
it says here on your resume you have
extensive computer experience
[Laughter]
no just need to make some extra money so
this kid
is going through a big surgery his
family needs a scratch and you certainly
have a lot of what we're looking for
huh we just don't like the kid thing i
noticed you didn't fill out the part
about any prior arrests
yeah that's just formality no one's
perfect
uh oh most recently i was arrested for
public intoxication
assault and battery willful destruction
of property i think they said
not necessarily in that order
arrested for assaulting a minor a miner
you know technically multiple miners you
know these kids are real pricks
it feels really good to talk about this
let me start mark no
johnny
here you're the one that's unstable
dancer is all about helping people
wasn't it a miyagi doe student who put
miguel diaz that's your girl
yeah i don't know sound like vanilla not
a flavor number one
you could just get some girl in the news
who's this could be any girl
how about you shut your mouth sorry ass
punk
is there a question marker okay give you
a free shot before i use your teeth for
dice
and karate is about self-defense see how
that works out
yeah self-defend yourself robbie but
subsequently work your way to the top
of the food chain in prison
[Music]
oh god they make these scenes hurt man
we ain't done
what do i want with a used laptop you
sold it to me used
well now it's more used it's these new
batteries
ran out of juice please don't run out of
juice did you plug it in
you said it was wireless wireless as in
never mind i don't own anything valuable
then i guess you better find someone who
does
man they're both falling apart what are
you gonna do gonna go round up your
biker friends
get your asses kicked again i thought we
weren't gonna talk
daniel if we want to come out of this
with anything
we're gonna have to sell the coal no
no don't quit it's not what mr miyagi
would have done with his car dealership
my mom had this station wagon it was
such a piece of junk
you literally had to push it to get the
engine started and then mr miyagi gave
me that 47 ford and
that was the best day in my life oh i
thought car salesman was sleazy
they're such a [ __ ] stereotype
miyagi told me
must follow passion man who worked for
passion
always richer than man who worked for
money
he was right was he though
if we don't sell to coal we might end up
with nothing why don't we um
go finish those inventories
i'm just gonna rub one out danny
that was the last time you and your wife
were into me
[Music]
nothing exists
pretty thin breathe out hey does it say
who's visiting me
lawrence john
oh ravi i hated you the first season
oh i remember that and i've grown to
really be fond of you buddy
oh is that ass in her back and he's
coming
he's back gender pay happy
feet
i don't want to be here any longer than
i have to how's that karate thing going
huh
it didn't go under did it oh dude
he's almost a hundred years old yeah
lasan
and your students talk about a role
model
hey easy there rocco it sounded like you
were warming up to ask for a
handout and i'd hate for anything to
jeopardize
another payday uh miguel doesn't deserve
what happened to him and i need to make
that right yeah with my
money
i'm trying to scrape together whatever i
can to help miguel's family
farm john learns
i said hey for that little incident with
your secretary get out to the public
you know start one of those hash brown
me too things
brown ash brown fish
you're a cold old man and don't you
forget it
buster just take something you can sell
yeah there you go
okay that's a bad plan [ __ ] bad plan
right here we'll make sure miguel knows
this
come on guys well you're gonna pay all
right [ __ ]
hawk he's evil he's just an evil
character
oh for roosh you are looking at the new
owner of larusso van nuys
not so fast tom we made some adjustments
page 9.
[Laughter]
i don't understand the dealership or not
when hell freezes
over i signed an exclusive deal with
doyona we know all about that
did you just write him out oh oh he was
okay with that okay
daniel offered me my job back since he
knows my name
and isn't a complete douche clown i
accept it
we've still got some moves well there's
no turning back now
it's playing better work bands back
together yeah still
wait wait what this isn't a sure thing
i hope we never focus on karate ever
again yeah it's all about the car
dealership cobra kai
took the money and they kicked the
[ __ ] [ __ ] out
they got an effort into the show
i didn't even think about the f work
growing up
it's for the dies kid to put toward his
hospital though it's very generous
can i tell the family who it's from i'd
prefer to leave my name out of it it's
all the same
oh this is this little well you're
getting the recognition
thank you johnny
oh it's a good thing she was there to
overhear him say he wants to leave his
name out of it absolutely pardon a
perfect humble moment
oh yeah i have to be somewhere
the dodgers are playing
please pray with us
okay i'll stay here give it a shot man
your best friend's a priest
yeah where's he
right there he's with robbie you gotta
handle this with robbie
oh he's with miguel oh
oh no burns just give him a little more
time
oh no no this is a misunderstanding
oh this is bad
oh why wouldn't they have gone together
it's not coming
oh cobra guy's never stopped training if
that means me taking the reins then so
be it
what sensei sam what what if your dad
finds out
he won't he's out of town and he's never
coming back
is he going to we gotta go in japanese
they are ready for you now oh my god
it's gonna be karate kid too
he runs toyota chosen
zack
oh
oh that's a clever way to tie it back in
i hadn't even thought of doing that but
that's closer
i was like where's this car dealership
plot going
it's going back to old flames and old
rivalries
yeah how about you guys those cobra
kayak dudes are a bunch of
dicks yeah i've never been a fan of them
and they're all
mean that was mean sometimes they do
things that i'm just like they're so
mean
like there's a version of being like
strong and tough and everything where
you don't just go out of your way to
make
anybody blow you's life miserable
oh my god they took bullying they take
bullying to the next level like it seems
like hawk and his friends
just hang out all day finding people to
victimize
gosh that was so messed up yeah it's
like they helped out me
come on man come on this is messed up
[Laughter]
yeah this is so mean it's just so
mean i can't i can't handle it man can't
stand for this
it's too mean someone's gonna have to
teach him a lesson
someone's gonna have to show him it
doesn't pay to be a
dick everyone's like yeah i know it's
cobra cud that's the point
i don't know sometimes you're just like
come on
why you gotta be so mean why well i mean
like
i not that it's just outlandishly mean
you know there's i don't it doesn't
bother me
but i do think that there is something
about especially hawking just like any
auxiliary cobra kai like really
surrounding him that yeah they just
are these like evil characters and like
in a show that's bothering to nuance
it's like we knew hawk in the beginning
when he wasn't cool but i feel like they
have
stopped nuancing that character once he
put his mohawk
yeah you know it's just like now he's
got one note he's a dick all the time
he's gonna make everyone else around him
a dick and he's gonna victimize whoever
he can
ah it's too bad just too bad but it's
led to sam now becoming
female leading karate lady sensei lady
lady karate
yes gender gender stuff genderqueer
gender gender stuff
this episode a lot of gender equality
what do i do
do i complain
it's not a big deal let's go with that
it's not a big deal she's perfectly
capable she grew up with danny who grew
up with mr miyagi's
she probably it's a natural turning
point and she sees how dickish everyone
is and she's got a
she's got a personal involvement in all
this so yeah
i don't mind it and it's kind of cool
they're all in the equal playing field
and watching her
rise then when robbie comes out of jail
he'll be working alongside sam that's
right i don't know what's going to
become a robbie inside there though
you know like he's going to earn respect
after getting his ass
maybe one more time she'll be like drink
my piss
yeah they're going to just come in and
start like taking it dumping his food
and like trying to force him to eat it
and then you know from there he'll snap
and he'll fully hulk out and he'll like
put that guy in a coma
turn into uh he's going to keep putting
people in cool turn into freaking
vince vaughn from that's a solo
shave his head by the end of the season
he's gonna go full-on just feral in
prison i wanna see what happens to
robbie i really like robbie man and it
was a pirate
it just really brought me back to i
remember when i hated this guy
i really really care about him yeah when
he's on screen i'm like oh he's got
really
he gets me in the feels i don't know
where it's going to go with that
every episode has its own theme and does
that this theme seem to have a little
bit about belief
is what this one dealt with obviously
one's where he goes to see his friend
who is a
pastor and then him praying with
miguel's family and getting the respect
back you know it's
such a good humble moment you know it's
such a good so
humble yeah he was like don't don't tell
him it's from me johnny lawrence yeah
i don't want them to know like they're
listening to watching me they're right
there
right behind me man thanks babe i've
been waiting here for 20 minutes
i was afraid someone was gonna steal
this check it's the best way to look
humble
the best way when they recognize you
i'm all of your humble moments too close
with an earshot of anybody you want cred
from
that's what i learned in today's episode
that was great that was fantastic it
seemed to deal with belief praying with
them but then even with danny larusso
having belief in
a time where everything is really all
odds are against him and it looks like
failure is right around the corner to
have faith that you can win it all back
that you can properly restore everything
even with miguel having to get to go
through the surgery and you know
talking about how yeah it's a miracle
doctor you know having like trying to
get your hopes up but you know it takes
some faith to make sure
the surgery can go well and he can get
back on the track he needs to get back
on
so i liked having that sort of be this
wrap around theme here and
also with the car dealership i always
did find it kind of funny
because i know that mr miyagi was always
like the miracle worker when it came to
the cars and stuff
i didn't really think about that it was
like oh yeah the car dealership how that
does tie in so much of mr miyagi
and i really love how they honed in
specifically on that in this episode of
what makes this car dealership so
important to him as i remember when i
first started this show i thought it was
kind of an odd
thing for him to be doing yeah but then
you know you tie it back in here you're
like yeah that's right it was so much
about
uh what changed daniel larusso's life
and so
having that having us be reminded of
that and i really do feel like with the
cousin he's always been a funny
character
but they're even earning it with the
audience of you liking him
more this time around as well i feel
like there's an added element in this
episode of yeah like the major themes
seem to be belief and also like
forgiveness or retribution because yeah
i mean like
his cousin's been kind of a comedic
side character for a while and now it
seems like he's actually kind of growing
into
an asset and it seems like yeah he's
just more of a character than he is like
a joke and even anush
coming back and you know after having
you know not spoken to daniel giving
them this crucial piece of information
and all that
also too you know even miguel's family
being open to the idea of johnny
at least you know being involved here
you know
after shunning him for so exactly yeah
that did heart
break my heart for robbie because it's
like the
it is the core conflict i feel like at
least for johnny is he's like i'm torn
between my
two kids you know and yeah to have him
like receive this moment of validation
you know being invited to pray before
miguel goes into his surgery but
at the cost of missing robbie entire
that's one of those things where part of
me was like damn he really couldn't have
scheduled this better
at all like he had to go first thing in
the morning but at the same time it's
it's it's a good dramatic thrust and it
makes me now wonder
because robbie's you know not gonna
probably respond to either of his
mentors now you know so what's gonna
happen to him yeah
i mean what do you mean by schedule he
had to he had to get the
check in there before the surgery
happened that's right
and and you can only visit on select
dates yeah i know so why don't you go
like
have you ever visited people in juvie
all the time
i do it's a regular thing it's the
biggest demographic
the way to keep those views up is to go
meet with people and she's jubie views
man
uvs you get the return of ed asner
that guy's like 99 years old i'm not
you're joking he's like 94 or something
really
i was like i was just glad he was god
you're still acting came to show back
up damn just grouch around for five
minutes
show up to be an [ __ ] for him to get
that little prized possession i wonder
how much he was able to give
in to the hospital at that point i know
how much was that piece of artwork yeah
because that nurse was trying to like
damn it's generous it's like yeah
this is like a twenty five thousand
dollar piece or something like it could
be working
it's funny actually because you brought
this up earlier and i actually don't
mind so like
you know every episode has had action of
some sort and fighting but i feel like
this is thus far a bit of maybe sans the
first episode a bit
less of a karate heavy epis uh a season
so far like this is definitely present
but i feel like especially in this
episode
it was more in like little fits and
bursts and whatnot which i feel like is
kind of a good thing because
i feel like they do best when they
temper that stuff because sometimes it
is over the top
and i feel like having a little bit of a
break from it for this episode and
dealing with
like part way through i was thinking to
myself like oh we are kind of dealing
with like
this car dealership business and and
other things more than we are just kind
of focusing on
swept johnny's leg at the top that's uh
that was probably one of the coolest
action sequence of the entire what are
you
talking about all miguel thinks about is
karate
that's true the kids are learning karate
again to go up against cobra kai
yeah i mean yeah in principle
i just wonder how all this is good i
have a really
hard time seeing how this is all tying
in though into one unified story
like this b story of the dealership and
going to japan
i'm excited for it just because i've
seen karate kid too
yeah that's what i'm excited for
but i'm like how does how does this tie
in to the
main big picture so i'm wondering what
experience is going to come from there
in other words like some loose threads
that have
come from that experience in japan so i
guess tying up that karate kid story
will help
but three episodes in got seven more to
go you know there's a lot more craziness
to ensue
but i think thematically this was on
point performances as per usual were
good
i like the inkling of romance that they
hinted at between miguel and sam
as well because i kind of root for them
more than i root for robbie and sam
yeah yeah like i like robbie a lot but i
root more for
miguel and sam than i do for robbie and
and sam it is that sort of core i don't
know there's something about that
first season romance between them that i
think is really endearing and it's funny
because i have no idea where they'll
go where they'll like end that off maybe
she won't end up with either of them
yeah but uh yeah it is kind of cool to
have it vague so that we can sit here
and uh yeah just
kind of have your opinion on which one
and i did like that scene between them a
lot
there's also the big fight scene john at
the at the juvie prison
yeah yeah i mean not there's no karate i
mean you said there's no karate
this is just a bit less focal than
perhaps in the previous two seasons thus
far because at the beginning of this
season everyone's up in arms about how
karate is corrupting the youth
and you know clearly going and kicking
ass to solve our problems didn't work at
the beginning of episode two
so i think karate is about more than
fighting it's about these principles and
the philosophies and that's what we
explore here
absolutely and that's what's being
thrown in here throughout
so so your white man crease mine only
thinks about it through the lens of the
fists
but john this is karate i believe it
when i see it
i believe it bloody fists and all
guys did you ever take karate
leave your thoughts down below on karate
subscribe
click that notification bell hit that
like button
thanks for checking us out on patreon
also
david gandy david david man you've had
some
crazy 20 20 end of the year experiences
and 2021 is only gearing up to be
another
crazy year for you but one thing we
haven't touched on
i know you had a little bit of a stroke
recently
but you were doing martial arts
you were doing martial arts and i think
post stroke the first thing you got to
do is put that key back on
put that bell back on and start taking
some
martial art zoom classes right away
again buddy
clear your living room you got to act as
if you are a man
of faith the way how this episode dealt
with faith combined faith
with your martial arts skills bam 2021
gonna be your kick-ass year
in in arizona where you're now at why
did you move to
right i've been telling you for years
that i was going to visit
up north and i just haven't done it how
about you left
is that why you left david because of me
oh
dude that must feel terrible you should
have made the effort i'm sorry you know
why the effort to go we'll come out and
we'll fight you and we'll settle this
like
men dude oh we could take on david yeah
we can post stroke weeds
we could definitely whoop your ass yeah
so
you better look out man better look out
better we're gonna whoop you away yeah
you better start training now if you
don't want to be
embarrassed when we show up in all
sincerity though david
we can kick your ass out
but we wouldn't but we won't we don't
want to me
because we only do it defensively all
sincerity
i hope 2021 ends up you're moving to a
new place
and you need to start off this year on a
much better i feel like
the way 2020 ended for you it's a sign
from god
going all right all terrible experiences
in 2020.
now 2021 is going to turn around for you
one of the roughest years i've had
anyone i know man it was like
unbelievably rough so in my eyes i'm
thinking 2021
is the year of opposite of 2020 for you
you're gonna have a good one
will it into existence prey on it punch
a baby in the face do whatever
it takes and then kick our asses i'll
see you soon david
we'll meet on the battlefield for honor